what his fate would be he did not know
but he felt that he was held for the
coming of that frightful soul and
messenger of infinities other gods the
crawling chaos the dweller of darkness
the faceless got the black Pharaoh near
laughs attempt unlike many of the other
day T's that appear in the Cthulhu
Mythos kneel off stop has an endless
list of names that he goes by with the
crawling chaos been the most widely
recognized kneel off the tip was first
mentioned by Lovecraft in a poem that he
wrote in 1920 he Lavrov described him as
a tall sinister man of a complexion that
suggests that he could have been an
Egyptian pharaoh the majority of the
story spent describing how any last step
is able to gather a legion of followers
with the use of strange enchanting
instruments as these fellows lose sight
of their own reality neela steps course
becomes their own and the story
eventually ends of the narrator becoming
a servant of Neill Arthur tipped and the
nightmare that he warned against
Lovecraft described his entire
experience as a nightmare and that is
because kneel a step is in fact based
off a nightmare that Lovecraft had
himself as a child loved Crawford then
go on to feature Neill off the tip in
the dream quest of unknown Kadath and
this time it is made very clear to us
that he does assume the form of an
Egyptian pharaoh we also learn that this
is just one of his many avatars that he
uses to roam the earth
Neela's head may only appear in four or
five stories but he's mentioned in
several more and he quickly became a
favorite of writers involved in love
crafts work and even those outside of
the mythos as a result of this he can be
found in all sorts of novels comics
games and even some manga and anime
where he actually appears as a teenage
schoolgirl looking for love but that is
something only for you guys to research
it was eventually established and Neil
Arthur step was the son of a Sothoth and
unlike many of the other great old ones
he was free to roam the earth as he
pleased and he's many avatars
interacting of humankind and acting as a
messenger Neel authorship is argh to be
the most used of all of the deities in
the entirety of the Cthulhu Mythos and I
feel like part of this comes down to the
fact that he's often depicted as the
most human God and I use the term human
quite lightly because he's said to have
around a thousand different forms and
many of these are far from human but he
does have several avatars such as the
Pharaoh we mentioned earlier that do
closely resemble human and this leads us
to one of his most obvious abilities the
ability to shape-shift the extent of
this power is unknown but we do know
that he can appear as a human and far
more disturbing monstrosities many have
theorized that he may in fact be capable
of mimic in the image of the
other gods and other days he's he may
not be as powerful as as I thought in
some of the other altar gods but Neil
Arthur tip doesn't must have an endless
list of powers that change depending on
which form he assumes these range from
immortality and invulnerability to
enhance strength and all forms of magic
but his greatest power lies in his
personality and the art of manipulation
unlike the other gods in a lot of cosmic
horror we can actually understand the
comprehend Neil Arthur tip as some of
his motives and desires appear to be
very human he is cruel sadistic and
manipulative he takes pleasure in
driving humans insane striking bargains
that he knows he cannot honor and
watching as those he manipulates seal
their own destruction being able to roam
freely amongst mortals in any shape or
form that he desires
spread in his vile agenda has fuelled
the belief that it won't be the beings
from outside that destroy our world but
Neil Arthur tip from within this is a
theory that I don't exactly agree with
Neil Arthur said does have the power to
destroy the what if that is what he
desired but I don't think he does
as someone who takes pleasure in
manipulation and spreading chaos it's
clear that humans may in fact be his
favorite toy there are other alien races
that exist in the Cthulhu Mythos but
he's chosen to make earth his home and
that could be because humans are the
most fun to torture what I do truly love
about the Cthulhu Mythos and what I find
myself continuously mentioning is how
open it is to interpretation I
personally think any last step is the
most complex and interesting of all of
the deities that appear in the Cthulhu
Mythos and my take on him is as follows
many people assume that he is the
messenger - as a thought on the outer
gods he does their bidding and through
him they will one day be brought forward
into our dimension I do agree that this
is perhaps why he was sent to our planet
in the very beginning but I think this
soon changed with Neil oft have been
extremely powerful but still in the
shadow of some of the other deities he
found himself on a planet where he could
reign supreme a planet that he could
corrupt from the inside he may still
remain loyal to Azeroth he's creator but
I don't think he owes other date is
anything he does serve a numerous of the
other gods cults by taking care of them
in their absence but that does raise the
question as to whether he's doing this
for his own benefit I don't believe that
Neil our step would destroy our planet
but rather what Ron in pleasure as it
burns and devours itself
cosmic aura and the fear of the unknown
is undoubtedly quite terrifying but I
think what makes Neil asked up such a
horrific figure is the fact that he
represents a very human evil the fear of
something you cannot comprehend
understand is one thing but the fear our
very own nature and the evil acts that
we are capable of committing is another
having now heard my interpretation of
Neil Arthur tip I'd love to hear yours
in the comments below as always I've
been your host mythology and fiction
explained